todas muitas outras que cem soldos
aliás essa é a rotina é da minha vida
sei lá quantos de quantos anos tenho 62
e é muito bonito aqui homens e mulheres
têm os mesmos direitos e anos vejam de
dourados onde vou falar como ele linhas
pensa-se blusol bom
hoje eu não vou falar de um tema é e eu
gostaria de estar somente 200 gols
somente para dizer que homens e mulheres
atingiu é verdade eu gostaria de dizer a
vocês - ainda que nosso trabalho foi a
maneira apesar de permitir eu começo a
falar de duas mulheres duas legendas
interrompidos
hoje em dia a dia de quem é a culpa
que corre é entender que já disse
elisângela a elas lixo em negar o
direito de decidir sobre seu corpo
o direito de decidir sobre seu destino
buscando resolver aquele momento
problemas que não dizem respeito às 16h
elas está o caminhos da morte
eu estou a dizer
no brasil nós poderíamos lançar no mundo
mais brasil 10
o aborto clandestino que ele toca em
duas gestões identificados
a primeira delas é a decisão do aborto
com esta questão quem decide o que fazer
a segunda questão é a dança dinheiro se
inicia vida de novo a discutir sempre
foi a mesma perspectiva
a vida começa assim toda a equipe atual
não é essa também a gente só deus e
machucam band imagem antes de sair e
arrieche para decidir os nas minhas gira
e a outra jovem não tiveram essa
oportunidade
em 2005 desembolse esperança dias
outras duas mulheres uma outra estavam
com o da desejada esperança de poder
interromper totalmente de forma segura
essa gestação
essa esperança ver é através de uma
comissão formada é pelo executivo pelo
parlamento e pela sociedade civil
essa comissão meses chegou a formulação
de um projeto de lei que define a
legislação sobre esse projeto atinge nós
xii movimento
mas sim fomos capazes de mudar
naquele momento a situação se apresentar
hoje é mais importante entendíamos que
eles são só sobre o aborto informar
transformar a percepção sobre a
sexualidade dos direitos sexuais e
reprodutivos feitas com uma pesquisa
feita em plena era de uma mulher do rei
é e pesquisado sobre o perfil do méxico
e responsáveis que engravidar porque o
direito à decisão
isso é importante assegurar direitos
sexuais
cerro só desses desses direitos na
sociedade e fazer gostar o beijo dizer
que essa situação caso dessas duas moças
brasil
rosa magri de apenas 10 por cento de
mulheres
o encenador advogará por nós temos um
desrespeito muito importante lá é que os
fundamentalismos e hoje o congresso
nacional câmara e senado a bancada
religiosa rígida
de 250 na conta de juros o brasil está
lá mas nós nesses anos e as deliberações
que esse país todo como estado-nação
baseados em dizer porque eu escolhi uma
música do meu tudo o que ele canta e
encanta e acaba botando o seu carinho
dos meus prediletos chico a abordagem
gente nos ajuda porque o jec sobre a dor
a dor dessa festa